[Música]
y hablamos ahora y revista de prensa de
hoy lunes 7 de marzo rosa bienvenida
comenzamos una semana también que
promete ser muy movida en todo el ámbito
noticioso con la guerra en ucrania y
mucho más pero ahora vamos a fijarnos en
la cobertura de esta guerra en ucrania
como lo hemos venido haciendo empezamos
con una información rosa que nosotros
encontramos en el medio independiente
ruso de moscú time pero que también hace
referencia a la exclusiva del washington
al rusia dice así estaría reclutando
sirios para combatir en ucrania según
fuentes del ejército de eeuu es decir
ver escenarios sirios para la guerra en
ucrania buenos días raúl efectivamente
como comentaba esta información la
encontramos en el moscú times y en
muchísimos medios de alrededor del mundo
pero es una exclusiva del wall street
journal y la información no proviene de
pues fuentes del ejército de eeuu y este
artículo pues se lo redactan gordon lowe
bolt nancy joseph y alan cool y son como
comentabas no moscú estaría reclutando
pues combatientes en siria donde
recordemos pues el ejército ruso está
pues combatiendo al lado de las fuerzas
de bashar al asad desde 2015 en esta
guerra en la que han intervenido
distintos actores como también eeuu o
francia contra el estado islámico
concretamente dice esta información
citamos textualmente un informe
estadounidense indica que rusia que ha
estado operando en siria desde 2015 ha
estado reclutando a combatientes allí
con la esperanza de que su experiencia
en combate urbano pueda ayudar a tomar
kiev y a dar el golpe definitivo al
gobierno de ucrania y según esta
información algunos de estos
combatientes ya se encontrarían en
territorio ruso preparándose para unirse
a esta invasión de ucrania sin embargo
no se es no se esclarece cuántos
exactamente combatientes se hubieran
unido a estas fuerzas rusas para esta
misión en particular y bueno como
comenta el wall street journal esto pues
dejan entrever una posible escalada de
la violencia en ucrania si esto es
posible pero recordó que también haya
combatientes extranjeros uniéndose al
bando ucraniano no sumándose a esta
legión extranjera creada por el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr ser en
skip vamos ahora a ross a ver el
reportaje del new york times' que narra
la preparación de los veteranos de
guerra de eeuu decididos a ir a luchar
del bando ucraniano rosa así este se
titula este artículo de day phillips no
puedo quedarme de brazos cruzados y es
precisamente una cita de un veterano del
ejército estadounidense pero digamos en
este texto si se citan muchísimas
fuentes ahí es que según nos informa el
'new york times' se están creando grupos
no de ex soldados estadounidenses a lo
largo y ancho del país de eeuu que pues
sienten la necesidad de ir a luchar del
lado de las fuerzas ucranianas pero es
que es muy curioso las razones que dan
no al periodista dice tal literalmente
este artículo del new york times'
después de servir durante años en
difíciles ocupaciones tratando de
establecer la democracia en lugares que
tenían poco interés en ella muchos
soldados muchos soldados están de lo que
ven como una lucha justa para defender
la libertad contra un agresor
autoritario y es que tal y como señalan
los soldados que dan su opinión en este
artículo algunos tienen ganas de volver
a sentir la adrenalina de la guerra pero
otros ven como lo ven como una
oportunidad de reparar las misiones
fallidas en irak o en afganistán de
hecho david rivard o uno de los
veteranos de guerra que es citado en
este artículo dice es un conflicto que
claramente tiene un bando bueno y uno
malo y quizá esto es lo que lo
diferencia de otros conflictos recientes
muchos de nosotros vemos lo que está
pasando y solo tenemos ganas de un
rifle e ir para allá solamente recordar
que el gobierno de eeuu está intentando
desalentar no estás digamos estas ganas
de soldados veteranos del ejército de
eeuu de ir a ucrania porque dice que
esto podría hacer escalar todavía más el
conflicto no hay que hay otras formas de
ayudar al pueblo ucraniano también rusia
ha dicho que no va a considerar a los
soldados extranjeros como soldados sino
milicianos y que pues no les va a
aplicar el derecho humanitario como
prisioneros de guerra reversa y
rápidamente continuamos entre el tema
referente a nuestros compañeros de
profesión es que distintos medios de
comunicación han decidido suspender
transmisiones desde rusia o sacar a sus
corresponsales qué pasa pues que después
de esta ley que fue aprobada el viernes
pasado en que se perseguía a las
personas que difundieran noticias falsas
sobre pues el ejército ruso distintos
medios de comunicación como la viviese
bloomberg civiles
radio televisión española efe están
suspendiendo sus actividades
informativas en rusia o digamos sacando
a sus periodistas del país por miedo a
que puedan enfrentarse tal y como
estipula esta ley a penas incluso de
cárcel rosa gracias entonces por toda
esta información mañana volvemos con más
de revista de prensa nosotros pasamos a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado el día